okay
last game of the day
against arthur coogan and
divis david martinez uh
apparently they're doing a
combined spanish stream
uh and uh at least arthur is um
is one of the coaches from
for uh for the challengers he's a pretty
has a very good reputation as uh as a
coach for sure
uh okay anyway we got d4
let's go last game of the day
and we're going to have another bank of
gambit
oh quincy 2
what do you do here i think you take
then for some reason
is e5 strong here is that way why goes
knight f3 no he was just trying to
confuse me
um
it looks a bit weird that he
instead of taking the pawn on a6 he's
got just given taking a b5 and taking an
a6
he's just
uh
yeah it's just chosen not to win the
pawn but his argument is that he
has quicker development and
that he's not have had to give up
any pawns on
uh sorry um he's not had to give up any
um
what am i saying he's not giving me an
extra open file on the iphone
and now
i think he can go for instance b3 here
yeah way too
tired at this point it's probably a good
thing that
this is the last game
i mean
i lost my speech
a couple of hours ago
since then it's been
it's been uh
it's been a pretty and can hear
incoherent rambling
and
dirty flagging that's been
that's been the whole content to be
honest
what do i do here
bishop g4
bishop g4 there's
92 and i kind of go 97 then
1970 as e5 which is annoying me
maybe knight b6 just wasn't a good move
okay we'll go 98
to c7 instead but i don't love it
but at least now i'm preparing in case
of
e5 to go knight c7 and put pressure on
on this one
yeah now i think i'll have to go bishop
b7 which looks awful
into this pawn but at least i'm
preventing
preventing e5 for the moment
and i may have plans of going queen
d7 and then f5 breaking everything open
so it's not like my position is
devoid of ideas
even if i'm
even if i'm uh
what was i saying
okay so once a5
driving the knight away and then e5
can i do too much about that
probably not i could play a5 myself but
then i give up the b5 square
i think i'll go bishop a6 instead
uh
okay we'll chop it off
it's fine by me
f5 still doesn't work
let's try and activate this knight then
i got ideas of c4 and also knight b4
spending too much time
this is when it gonna be a uh
scramble i think eventually let's go
knight a8 and then knight c7 i think
that was a better square than c8
he's psyching upon okay
i'll gladly
gladly capture your pawn sir
knight c7
he does have compensation but i don't
think i'm worse we'll take it
yeah i think he's
just uh
doing way too much at this point
this doesn't work at all
queen f5
protecting everything
well
now just keep grabbing pawns it's a
little bit like my game against goo cash
in that sense okay we'll just trade
queen g4 and then
rook t2 95 and where three pawns up and
c pawn is running
so that's okay we'll go h5 i don't want
to give him
even gonna give him a check
okay rook c8
knight c3 to a2 or e2
take it
okay he lost some time but obviously
um
obviously um
i was more than enough to win